holy [ __ ] as I said
welcome home
in many ways Gears of War for knows
exactly what makes this series great to
begin with and capitalizes on those
strengths and myriad ways in other
respects however the sequel feels like a
misstep as the gears franchise continues
on its story path the result is a
fractured mix of inspiration boredom and
exhilaration
the storyline follows JD Phoenix the son
of series regular Marcus Phoenix as he
battles a new subterranean threat and
the coalition of ordered government's an
organization that has taken a sinister
turn since the original Gears of War
trilogy the younger Phoenix travels with
new characters kate and del both of whom
revealed backgrounds and familial ties
the plot progresses unfortunately much
of this narrative feels forced or
predictable the gears franchise is
always hidden a quality story beneath
its macho jargon and shallow jokes but
new studio the coalition doesn't find
much depth here in its storytelling the
humor is irritating romances emerge on
an insincere whim and I never felt as if
the characters actually cared about each
other dialogue serves mainly as
exposition without the nuances that
could otherwise flesh out complex
relationships among the cast they're
gonna mess up my [ __ ] tomato what's
more the actual gameplay suffers from
pacing and redundancy problems
throughout the campaign the first two
hours are the most abrasive throwing
multitudes of simple enemies at JD and
his gang is they true through waves with
conventional weapons and boring
situations it takes several chapters
until firefights evolve past simple
point-and-shoot scenarios but even then
the campaign seems intent on repeating
situations time and time again turret
defense sequences frantic fights against
weaker nimble enemies and the simple act
of clearing an area before a loud gong
beckons you to the next skirmish this
lack of inspiration is all the more
frustrating considering the engaging
scenarios that do emerge Gears of War 4
introduces several mini bosses that
demand a new approach to the franchise's
tried-and-true combat and mitigate the
feeling of deja vu as the chapters pass
there are also several campaign sections
that make use of Gears of War fours new
horde mode planting it directly in the
narrative during defensive scenarios
with JD and its squad
in Gears of War for horde mode is
fantastic
whereas Gears of War 3 is overextended
itself trying too hard to expound upon a
solid formula the wave defense mode has
found both confidence and creativity in
its newest iteration there's a handful
of new mini bosses that arrived on the
scene every 10th wave to pound you with
artillery or charge your position with
Klaus Ray's and rather than have you
build turrets and set locations horde
now gives you a fabricator a portable
station lets you buy weapons and
defenses to build strongholds around the
map Gears of War 4 also introduces
upgradable character classes to the
Horde formula asking you to fill a role
on a team of up to 5 players there's a
sniper a heavy and an engineer devoted
to maintaining defensive emplacements
while classes seem like a forced
addition on paper they result in some of
the best cooperative scenarios I've seen
in the Gears of War franchise Gears of
War force versus section displays the
same quality craftsmanship as its
wave-based counterpart of the new modes
present in the sequel several showcase a
more arcadey side of the franchise's
player versus player combat arms race
grants each team specific weapons as
they progress through the match
demanding new strategies as you cycle
from the explosive boom shot to the
close-range nation' to the final weapon
the bull [ __ ] pistol my favorite mode
however is dodgeball as in its
real-world counterpart you have the
chance to tag teammates back into the
match after they've been eliminating
simply by removing one of your opponents
it's a battle of attrition where one
player can turn the tide changing a
three versus one match into an even bout
or turning the tables completely to gain
the upper hand it's worth noting that
Gears of War 4 does suffer from some
technical issues in both its multiplayer
and story modes certain objectives
didn't trigger during my campaign
forcing me to restart the last
checkpoint and replay sometimes boring
chapters the game also froze several
times in the menus as it tried to load a
match or even just the next menu page
these problems don't ruin the overall
experience but they're irritating enough
to cast a pallor over some of the games
sections
and that serves as a microcosm for the
entirety of Gears of War for this is a
shooter teetering on the edge of
something greater
but despite the improvements it makes to
the storied franchise its missteps hold
it back there is inspiration here and
creativity in the way Gears of War for
rethinks its multiplayer modes but the
lackluster campaign and technical issues
are blights on an otherwise exhilarating
shooter the result is a hole that
doesn't reflect the quality of its often
stellar parts not a goddamn word
[Applause]
you